All right.
Welcome to our educational session on fibroblast dynamics,
how heterogeneity shapes the tumor microenvironment.
I'm going to be talking a lot about fibroblasts.
And you have this QR code up, so this is how you can go
online and type in questions. We also have two microphones.
You are more than welcome to come up and ask questions at the microphone.
But if you'd like to type your question online, that's the QR code,
and then it will pop up on the computer here so we can read out your question.
All right.
Great.
All right. Do you want to come up?
No. Okay.
All right. My name is Stephanie Duggan.
I'm an associate professor at Dana-Farber Cancer Institute and Harvard
Medical School, and we'll be talking to you today about fibroblasts and
anti-tumor immunity.
These are my disclosures.
All right. So when we think about fibroblasts, this is one of the most
fundamental cell types. It's part of
every normal healthy tissue. These are the cells that are
making your connective tissue, performing lots of structural
functions, and although this
session is about fibroblasts and cancer, I do want to iterate that these
are normal cells that are very important for homeostasis.
And they're not just one kind. And so if you look in various
tissues, the fibroblasts are poised for separate
functions in those tissues. All of them make extracellular matrix, some more
than others. But they also have a lot of metabolic functions.
They can secrete a lot of proteins.
These are cells that are really good at protein biosynthesis that's important
for making extracellular matrix, for remodeling extracellular matrix.
But they can also do things like secrete growth factors and cytokines
that can call in immune cells as needed or restrain them as needed.
And so this is a picture form, but it actually comes from a
lot of transcriptional profiling.
This is a really nice study from Shannon Turley's group, where
they looked at healthy tissues, and you can see the
tissues here. And a lot of them were public data sets where
they subsetted out fibroblasts and just asked, "What does the fibroblasts look like
in lung, in bone, in intestine?" And
they're slightly different. And so you see that there's some
heterogeneity. They're all capable of making extracellular
matrix, but they have slightly different gene transcriptions that make
the normal functions that are needed in those tissues.
A huge function, of course, is to produce the extracellular matrix.
We think of this in terms of collagens, but there's also a lot of
proteoglycans in there. Huge amount of ECM
components. This is an incredibly diverse set of
proteins that can be cross-linked in long fibers, that
can be cross-linked
in a more chaotic way. And a lot of the
remodeling of the extracellular matrix is also performed by fibroblasts.
Macrophages can contribute, too.
But in terms of both building and breaking down collagen, making
matrix metalloproteases to make sure that the
extracellular matrix is appropriately remodeled.
This is a cartoon, but also some really nice work.
This study was led by Richard Hynes' lab,
asking what proteins are there? And I think proteomics has
really led the way in this, where you can take the extracellular matrix from a
tissue, you can decellularize it, and ask, "Well, what is left?"
And it's a surprisingly rich set of proteins,
some of which are the core matrisome that are
detected across
tissues, but some of them are also more tissue-dependent.
And asking what does a tissue need in its extracellular matrix can be very
revealing about the function of the fibroblasts that secreted it in the first
place, and that tissue in particular.
And so we talked a bit about healthy homeostasis, but of
course, tissues can become inflamed.
And one of the huge important roles of the fibroblasts is
to sense tissue damage and to help mediate the
wound healing and remodeling of the extracellular matrix.
And
so the same subset of fibroblasts that we just surveyed
across healthy tissues also has a counterpart
in diseased tissues
that look slightly different, but are oftentimes recruiting
in innate inflammatory cells, so they make a lot of chemokines.
These are your CCL and CXCL family of proteins,
which form gradients that are deposited in the
extracellular matrix that allow for things like monocytes and neutrophils
to come in.
Monocytes, of course, can differentiate into macrophages and help
with that wound repair and tissue healing.
All right.
And this is going on in cancer. It's going on
at a much higher rate. And so cancer was
originally described as a wound that doesn't heal.
And so many of these activation of fibroblast pathways, of
course, are also happening in cancer. They're happening chronically.
They're happening for a long time.
And many of the processes that we think about in terms of cancer directly
act to activate fibroblasts. And so certainly, these are
contact-dependent signalsWith the
cancer cells and extracellular matrix,
DNA damage, factors like TGF-beta, which we're going to talk a lot
more about, and stress induced by hypoxia or
reactive oxygen species, can certainly all activate these sort
of constitutive fibroblasts that are present in whatever tissue the
cancer is arising in and turn them into this so-called CAF.
This cancer-associated fibroblasts.
And so we've appreciated these for a long time, that they're in all
cancers. They seem to be really bad or at
least complicated and sort of appreciating that they
have an origin with the normal tissue
is an important
point to note.
And so although we have CAFs in every cancer type,
we are today going to use as an example pancreatic
cancer. And so our speakers today all are sort of
active in the pancreatic cancer field.
And the reason that pancreatic cancer has kind of led the way in thinking about
fibroblasts is because it is highly desmoplastic.
I have a cartoon that I drew here, but you can also see from the H&E
that you have these tiny nests of cancer cells that are the dark
purple,
that are kind of in this giant sea of extracellular matrix.
And so you have these activated fibroblasts making this huge amount of
stroma that can,
by its sheer biomass, outweigh the actual cancer cells themselves.
And so this has been appreciated for a very long time.
And so
how can we
therapeutically intervene? And I would say that we're going to talk
about all of these strategies to either deplete
fibroblasts or the extracellular matrix, and this kind of makes sense.
You look at something like pancreatic cancer, it has a very horrible prognosis.
It's got all of this desmoplasia. And so the obvious
thought is, okay, well, maybe that stroma is
contributing to progression of the tumor, and so what can we do about it?
And so these are strategies that have been tried.
We'll talk about Smoothened inhibitors,
pegylated hyaluronidase to enzymatically digest the extracellular
matrix,
blockade of two different cytokines, and CAR T cells.
All right. And so what is Smoothened?
This is a cartoon from Sunil Hingorani's lab, who's worked on this
quite a bit, where the tumor cells themselves can
make these Hedgehog ligands that will bind to
Patched1, which is a natural inhibitor of the Smoothened
protein, which can then
prevent it from signaling. And if you block this pathway, then Smoothened will
naturally activate these Gli transcription factors, and this can lead
to proliferation and activation of these fibroblasts.
And so there was a seminal study published a while ago now by Ken
Olive's group,
when he was in Tev Tuveson's lab, looking at, okay, well, maybe
can we use these Smoothened inhibitors to try to kind of
debulk this extracellular matrix with the
observation, as you can see in these pictures, that if you have
a pancreatic tumor growing in a spontaneous so-called
KPC gem mouse,
it's this dark spot in the middle. And what is this dark spot?
Well, this is looking at sort of a fluorescent gemcitabine
trying to get in, and you can see that the drug is able to get everywhere in the
pancreas but not the tumor. Right?
And so it was sort of obvious, like okay, it's very dense.
You try to cut into this, it's very hard, like a rock.
Maybe if we got rid of that extracellular matrix by sort of inhibiting these
fibroblasts, could we get more drug in?
And so gemcitabine is one of the
chemotherapies used in pancreas cancer, and you can see in the mouse model that
combination of the Smoothened inhibitor with gemcitabine is able to extend
survival in an incredibly difficult mouse model.
So this had some unfortunate results in humans,
though. And I do want to kind of show you the mouse and the human
data. And so the initial trial that was
started right on the heels of this pre-clinical study was using
a Smoothened inhibitor,
that's listed here, where the trial had to stop
early. This was not actually published, but it was released by the company,
that the Smoothened inhibitor plus gemcitabine actually made the tumors progress
faster than with chemotherapy alone.
A second trial was done where you can see that there was not really
much of a difference, but I think that this early press release
really was a huge wake-up call to the field saying,
"Wow, we really don't understand fibroblasts." We show that we
can deplete them or sort of quiesce them, and this idea that
we just get more drug in
ended up making the patient's survival worse.
Similarly, there have been strategies to try to deplete the extracellular
matrix, and so pegylated hyaluronidase, this is an enzyme that kind
of cleaves up hyaluronic acid, sort of pictured here in
yellow. And
if you look by immunohistochemistry, you can see that there's a range
of hyaluronic acid in pancreatic cancer in humans, some of which
can be quite, quite high. And so if you are able
to digest this enzymatically, then maybe you'll sort of dedensify that
extracellular matrix. The blood vessels are going to be less
compressed, and you'll be able to get more drug in.
And so the initial Phase II trial with gemcitabine and
paclitaxel, listed here as AG, was
promising. Although in Phase III, you can see that there was really
no effect of using the pegylated hyaluronidase to
increase chemotherapy delivery to the tumor.
And
very strikingly, if you just change the chemotherapy
regimenAnd this is now FOLFIRINOX,
which is
used very frequently in first-line pancreas cancer.
You can see that these labels are not mixed up, that in fact,
depleting the extracellular matrix with pegylated
hyaluronidase worsens overall survival.
And so
this again sort of had a moment of reckoning for the
field where we thought, well, maybe there's something about this, that
there's fibroblast heterogeneity.
Are there some fibroblasts that are actually good, that are sort of tumor
restraining, and maybe we need to understand this better.
And so
this led to some initial discoveries on sort of bucketing
fibroblasts into multiple subsets.
And one of the first ways of thinking about this was looking
at transcriptional profiling. And you could see, this is work
from Julia Biffi when she was with Dave Tuveson, that the
fibroblasts that are next to the cancer cells, that are sort of surrounding
these little cancer cell nests, receive a lot of
TGF-beta signaling, and they become these sort of
myofibroblastic-like CAFs or myCAFs.
These make a lot of extracellular matrix.
They have direct contact with the tumor cells.
Whereas the fibroblasts that are sort of further away
are not getting as much TGF-beta signaling, and they can
see more sort of IL-1, as it induces this phenotype.
And they're making some extracellular matrix, but a lot of
cytokines and chemokines that are interacting with the immune system.
So IL-6 is hugely produced by these fibroblasts,
as is the Th2 alarmin IL-33, as well as
complement proteins. And so these were termed inflammatory
fibroblasts or iCAFs, thinking there would be an interface
with the immune system. And when we said, "Oh, okay, look, there are two kinds of
fibroblasts. Maybe there's the good kind and the bad kind."
And so this has now been tried in humans.
Okay, we know that there are cytokine signals that prevent or
preclude development
of these sort of iCAFs and myCAFs. And so I'm going to show you data
from a blockade of TGF-beta, which should
deplete the myCAFs, not the iCAFs, and IL-1 beta
blockade, which should have the converse effect.
And so this is the mouse data. This was done in my lab, where we looked at
TGF-beta blockade in a mouse model of pancreas cancer, showing that it
nicely prevents signaling through phospho-SMAD2.
And if you look at fibroblasts, you can see that indeed, the sort of
alpha-SMA positive myCAFs were depleted.
That was statistically significant.
So the drug sort of does the thing we thought it was supposed to do.
But the trials in humans have been very
disappointing. In fact, kind of in the same vein of, wow,
this backfired.
This is showing the published data, which is primarily
lung cancer and colorectal cancer, but the trial of TGF-beta
blockade with gemcitabine plus paclitaxel in
pancreas cancer was actually stopped in phase three
for a
worsening of overall survival.
So
this is not the path to go down.
Similarly, we've looked at IL-1 beta blockade.
Most of the data that's
firmly established is in lung cancer, where there was a very promising signal that
sort of early blockade of IL-1 beta could prevent the formation
of lung cancer.
I think that's still true, but if you have patients who have established lung
cancer, these were three very disappointingly
negative trials where it just didn't do anything.
And this is data we were involved in, in pancreas cancer, where although
this waterfall plot looks a little better, it really doesn't
beat out chemotherapy alone, suggesting that there
was not a big effect of IL-1 beta blockade in
pancreas cancer.
So perhaps a little more promisingly, I don't want to leave you with
such a depressing historical run through our clinical trial
history.
CAR T cells have been developed that target fibroblast
activating proteins of FAP, which is expressed on many fibroblasts.
This is the mouse model
showing that, in fact, you can deplete FAP-positive
fibroblasts. Alpha-SMA goes down, so the CAR T cells
have their mechanism of action, and they can
control pancreas tumors quite well, sort of maintaining stable
disease for a long time.
And I think encouragingly, the CAR T cell doesn't
even necessarily have to deplete the fibroblasts.
And so this is a very interesting study where there is
a CAR T that was developed to target a fibronectin splice
variant that is unique to the extracellular matrix of many cancers,
including pancreas cancer. In this case, it's actually a melanoma example,
where
you ask yourself, why would you make a CAR T cell that doesn't even kill a
cell, right? It's targeting a protein in the extracellular matrix.
That seems like a ridiculously futile effort.
And yet you can see that the tumors are controlled quite well
in these mice. And when we looked by
immunohistochemistry, you can see that you get this massive
influx of activated T cells, a reopening of
CD31 here, so these are nicely patented blood vessels.
And the
effect is likely due to just localizing the CAR T as a major
source of interferon gamma that reprograms that whole
tumor microenvironment. And it doesn't really matter that it doesn't actually kill
any cells.All right. So I've sort of left
you with, well, maybe there's some fibroblast heterogeneity.
Are there any clearly good or bad fibroblasts?
And we've talked most about how to bucket them by transcriptional states,
where you have kind of this iCAF, myCAF.
This is really only one way to think about them.
And I would say that my colleagues here, Klaus and Mara,
have contributed a lot to understanding, are there
nuances of how you can define these cells better?
This is a figure from Mara's recent review, which goes
into all the different ways of looking at cell of origin, surface
markers, with the hope that maybe if we just figured out
who were the really, really good fibroblasts, that maybe we could
keep those and reprogram the other ones.
And so to that end,
this is a study
looking at sort of
epidemiologically, whether
there was a signal for overall survival by
subdividing cancer-associated fibroblasts and sort of
promoting CAFs, these pro-CAFs or restraining CAFs,
which mirror similarly the iCAF, myCAF
designation, but are slightly differently based.
And this is kind of the biggest effect you can see in shifting those overall
survival curves, which, I mean, all of you are looking at this as P value
significant, but pancreas cancer is really bad, and
so what are we actually going to succeed in if
all we're doing is shifting the fibroblast subsets?
So is this the best we can hope from it?
I do want to mention briefly a sort of minor population of
fibroblasts that came along with the sort of iCAF, myCAF
designation that there was appreciated to be a smaller
subset, more rare, that express MHC class II.
I love this. I'm primarily an immunologist, and so this is
how cells present antigen to CD4 T cells, your helper
T cells, and so what is it doing on a fibroblast?
And so this,
I think to understand it fully, we need to go back to sort of what are these
fibroblasts doing in the normal pancreas.
And this is a really nice study looking
in diabetes
models, and actually in humans with pre-diabetes, where you can see that you
have the islets here, right? And these islets are surrounded by
these class II positive fibroblasts. And what are they doing?
They're there so that you can present antigen
to a CD4 T cell, but turn it into a Treg, a regulatory
T cell. And this way, you can prevent autoimmune
diabetes and also pancreatitis. So I think this is a very important natural
process by which the pancreas promotes immune tolerance
rather than destruction. So summarized in
this title here, Tregs provide a critical buffer against diabetes and
pancreatitis. But of course, if you have the misfortune to develop
pancreatic cancer,
you're doing so kind of on this background of a lot of Tregs, which can
inhibit anti-tumor immunity.
Whoops. All right.
So where do we go? Are fibroblasts sort of cause or consequence in
cancer? I think we've seen from trial after trial that just
depleting fibroblasts is maybe not the way to go.
So I've listed some kind of fibroblast-adjacent strategies,
which
involve sort of either blocking downstream signaling in the tumor cells.
It's known that the tumor sort of relies on focal adhesion kinase
for support from those fibroblasts, and so these trials are actually looking pretty
promising. And then kind of going after the immune
profiling angle, can we deplete Tregs?
We actually have these new Fc enhanced CTLA-4 antibodies that do this pretty
well. So this I'm actually really excited about.
And can we sort of shift that cytokine balance by
either delivery of Th1 polarizing cytokines,
or there's some hint that CD40 agonism also acts by massively
reprogramming the extracellular matrix.
All right. A few take home messages here that I'll let you read, and
open it up to questions.
All right. Thank you. First question.
Is this on? Can you hear me?
Yes.
Okay, great. Great talk, great overview of all the clinical space and pre-clinical
space.
Probably not an unoriginal question, but thinking about all the experiments
we did pre-clinically, and then trying to translate them into clinics,
is this
us not understanding the therapy and how it works, or is this a limitation of the
mouse models that we've been trying in, and really it's just not reflecting the
clinical space that we don't really understand in humans?
Yeah, I think that's a great question.
I mean, how do we model this in order so that our models give us the
correct answer that will be what we see in trials?
And
I don't think this is just a mouse-human difference.
I think a lot of this is a time course difference.
And so fibroblasts are very plastic.
They can reprogram incredibly well.
And so if it's one kind of fibroblast today, it doesn't mean it can't shift its
phenotype. And so I think in the short course of the mouse models, we don't
necessarily capture that. How are we going to do this better?
There's certainly human sort of organoid fibroblast co-culture
data that's coming out. Does that really tell you long term?
Probably not. I think at this point, we should just look at
what the trial data that we have done are telling us and say
we had enough patients go through these efforts that
perhapsWe need to have just learned our lesson by now,
and say, what are the downstream effects of fibroblasts?
And are any of those individually targetable that might kind of be
more selective way? Yeah.
Edie.
I want to put you on the spot a little bit, because I learned something
from you that I think that most people would like to learn as well,
I hope.
You
enlightened me to understand what the reticular
fibroblastic cells do in lymph nodes.
And I wonder whether you think that the local fibroblasts in the
pancreas initially, the ones that
are making sure that the precancerous lesions don't go to
cancer in most of our cases, whether those are
similar and whether
that's what we're calling maybe the AP-CAFs.
Yes. I mostly focused on the CAFs in the tumor microenvironment.
Of course, fibroblasts are everywhere. They play a critical role in the lymph node.
But I think when we're talking about Class 2 positive CAFs, which I do try
to use that term, AP-CAFs or antigen-presenting CAFs has also been thrown
around. But that implies you're priming a T cell to go do something, right?
And the
fibroblasts universally never have co-stimulation, so
they don't have that second signal that tells the T cell, "Oh, this is
an infection. You should go fight it." And so it ends up
polarizing towards these regulatory T cells, which is an important and
critical role to say, okay, if it ends up on Class 2 on a
fibroblast, this is in quiescence.
You should not make an immune response. You should tolerize.
Yeah.
Thank you. You just answered my question.
It's about the AP-CAF. So I have another question.
It's about the extracellular matrix, because we think more in
biophysical properties. But there are more data that are
actively involved in immune response.
The proteoglycans, they are activating different kind of receptors.
So what do you think about that ECM, like immune
component that is giving maybe immunosuppressive effects or no?
So your question is about the cytokines or chemokines that are in the extracellular
matrix?
No.
Or I don't think I quite heard you.
Just the ECM itself acting like active
immune effector in the T cells, the microphages also.
Because there are a lot of proteoglycans that are agonists of different,
TLR4 and the other. So ECM is now produced by
myocaf, but also have active component in the microenvironment,
right?
Yes. So certainly if you're talking about immune cells crawling around in a tissue,
they do so on the extracellular matrix.
And so CD44, which is on activated immune cells, does bind
hyaluronic acid on extracellular matrix.
So it's a critical part of how cells crawl through the tissues.
And as they're doing that, they of course, can see whatever else is deposited in
the matrix. And so I really love the proteomic analyses to ask,
what proteins are there? Which you can miss by
transcriptional profiling, because it doesn't necessarily correlate with the RNA
of the cells you're identifying.
Thank you. When you're studying fibroblast-mediated
signaling and immune exclusion, specifically, let's say in PDAC,
are there specific spatial scales where there might be the most
strongest effect size in signaling?
Considering contact dependent versus maybe global tissue architecture.
Are there two?
That is a great question, and certainly, I think we're still
understanding how far things diffuse.
So a lot of the contact dependent mechanisms are obviously it has to be
the cell touching it. And so you get a lot of integrin signaling
happening between fibroblasts and cancer cells, fibroblasts and immune cells.
But the secreted molecules can diffuse.
Now, they don't diffuse like it's empty space because it's a lot of dense pressure
there. And so,
they sort of deposit in these gradients with some cytokines being very
localized in growth factors, and some kind of extending further out.
And so, really nice work on looking at
cells that are receiving the signal, like through phosphorylated
transcription factors, and can you ask sort of from the cell that produces it, how
many cell bodies away can you still see the response to that signal?
And I think it does differ for different
molecules. But it's a great area of research.
Maybe we'll take one more question, and then do we have any online?
Okay, great.
Okay. Thank you. Great presentation.
And my question is regarding the type of cancers you have, because you
started the presentation saying that pancreatic cancer is highly
desmoplastic. But does the
exocrine pancreas, if you have a neuroendocrine
pancreas tumor, it's not so desmoplastic.
So the different type of cancer drive different responses in the same
fibroblast.
Have you
done something like that, seeing which signals are given by one cell to
respect to another, and not treating the fibroblast as a unique
species that respond always the same?
Yes, that is a great question. I'm glad you bring up pancreatic neuroendocrine
tumors, because again, it tells you same organ, very, very different histology,
very different results in sort of activation of fibroblasts.
And so certainly there is crosstalk even with the
neoplastic cells as well. And so a lot of really good work done, I'd say senescent
cancer cells and sort of how they produce a lot of cytokines that could activate
fibroblasts and give you more of the sort of iCAF phenotype.
And the neuroendocrine tumors also make a lot of different factors.
I don't know if my panel wants to contribute more towards PNETs.
But you see this giant inflammatory reaction, and
yet, the tumor's progressing, right?
So not all inflammation is good. Just like not all fibroblasts
are good, but they could certainly act very differently.
Thank you.
Okay.
All right. Maybe last question. Yeah.
Thanks.
I have a question. Since you say that depletion might not be the right way to go,
what do you think about reprogramming and programming, let's say, from yeah
protumoral to anti-tumor fibroblasts?
Yes. So I think this is a very active area of research.
Can we reprogram a fibroblast? We know they're very plastic, so is there some
kind of signal we can give therapeutically that will keep them in whatever
the good state is?
I think we
want to be really sure we know what that good state is,
first, and how well or how
permanent that reprogramming is.
I think you're also stuck with, as soon as you stop using the drug, you can get it
to revert. So,
similar ideas have been proposed for macrophage reprogramming as well, and I
think it goes down a slippery slope of, is this
really the effect you want, and how long can you sustain that?
So I think there's a role for this fibroblast
reprogramming, but I think it's in combination with
other therapies that are either directly killing tumor cells or inducing an
immune response that can make that sort of transient
nature of the fibroblast reprogramming permanent.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you.
I will
introduce my colleague, Mara Sherman.
All right. Well, thank you, chair extraordinaire, Stephanie, for the opportunity to
participate in this session and for starting us off so nicely.
So my lab studies cellular hierarchies in the tumor microenvironment,
and our goal really is to understand how this immune-suppressive, chemo-resistant
microenvironment gets established, but also how it might be
dismantled for therapeutic benefit.
No disclosures.
So in this vein, we spend a lot of time thinking about mesenchymal elements such as
fibroblasts. And really our motivation is evidence from context
of development, health, and inflammation that
fibroblasts provide critical instructive cues that
regulate epithelial cell state and tissue function.
So for example, in the embryo, the splanchnic mesenchyme
critically instructs alveolar airway epithelium formation
in the developing lung, and that epithelial mesenchymal crosstalk
remains critical for lung function in early life.
In healthy adult tissue, there are positionally defined
populations of fibroblasts that secrete distinct developmental
cues that program epithelial heterogeneity in a way that's critical for
tissue function, and this is really nicely exemplified along the length of the
intestinal crypt.
And in the context of inflammation, there's a beautiful recent example from the
mighty reindeer showing that anatomically distinct populations
of fibroblasts can respond to similar wounding
insults with totally different secretomes, and therefore
different impacts on the epithelial compartment.
So specifically, a wounding insult to a regenerative organ, in this
case, specifically the velvet or the antlers, causes those fibroblasts
to secrete regenerative factors, stem cell niche
cues that ultimately promote epithelial cell proliferation,
regeneration, and tissue repair.
Whereas a really comparable wounding insult on the back skin
causes fibroblasts really to enter an inflammatory state and
ultimately result in epithelial cell death and a scarring
reaction. And importantly, really comparable fibroblast transcriptional
states are found in human skin in the fetus versus the
adult. And so, of course, we know that there are these
intrinsic differences among these positionally or anatomically
defined fibroblast populations, and we're motivated to understand how
about this epithelial mesenchymal crosstalk and fibroblast
heterogeneity in the context of cancer.
So there
has long been evidence that fibroblasts can really have heterogeneous
functional impacts on cancer cell growth.
Almost 60 years ago now, Michael Stoker's lab
demonstrated that normal static fibroblasts could suppress the
growth of polyoma transformed cells.
This was really an early example that components of normal tissue
architecture could serve as barriers to tumor genesis.
About 20 years later, pioneering work from Mina Bissell's lab in the chick
embryo comparing tumor progression in an uninjured versus
a clipped or wounded chick wing showed that a local
fibroinflammatory or wounding reaction was permissive to Rous
sarcoma virus-mediated tumor formation.
This was really a seminal example of a principle that's been shown many
times since, that a fibroinflammatory microenvironment can
promote tumor genesis.
So we study these networks in the context of pancreatic cancer really because, as
Stephanie so nicely described, these really are the
poster child of a fibroinflammatory malignancy.
So pancreatic cancer certainly exhibits heterogeneity from patient to
patient, but these tumors generally share two common
features. One is activating mutations in KRAS, something you'll no doubt
hear very much about at this meeting, and the second is that
during disease progression, the epithelial compartment
coevolves with this progressively dense
desmoplastic stroma. And the stroma, of course, includes abundant immune
cells and extracellular matrix components and is really set up by a
prominent population of cancer-associated fibroblasts.
So it stands to reason that during this dynamic coevolution of
epithelium and stroma, these fibroblastic
cells may very well have totally different molecular profiles
and functional consequences over time with respect to tumor
progression. So as a field, we've really learned
a great deal about factors or functions that fibroblasts
gain during tumor progression. As a community, we've seen
really nice studies showing that a CAF can produce immune
suppressive cytokines, chemokines, matrix components, and other
factors that can promote tumor genesis.
And in enacting this perturbed wound-healing response in the context of cancer,
they can also engage functions that are tumor restraining, including
engaging Hedgehog signaling, as Stephanie talked about earlier.
And there's also some really nice evidence that collagen I production can have some
tumor-restraining consequences as well.But what
we've really learned less about as a community is factors that are
expressed in normal tissue mesenchyme and that are lost over the
course of tumorigenesis,
which may potentially be barriers to tumor progression.
So really our motivation to think about this comes from
these pioneering studies from the labs of Laura Wood and Marina
Pawlikowska-Magliano that sort of took our collective breath away in
reporting that most adults, including
donors with no evidence of cancer, walk around with
pre-invasive lesions called PANNs in our pancreas.
So just as many of us walk around with BRAF mutant moles on our skin,
many of us walk around with KRAS mutant lesions in our
pancreas. The good news is that these lesions
vastly outnumber cases of invasive pancreatic
cancer. But the frequency of these lesions, this new normal
or newly appreciated normal, really compels us to ask why?
What are the mechanisms active in many of us that are keeping these lesions
from progressing to invasive cancer?
And can we learn from those mechanisms about biomarkers for
those at risk of progression and/or for preventative strategies?
So I think it's very likely that tissue-level tumor suppression
takes three forms. One, of course, is epithelial cell intrinsic mechanisms,
expression and activity of p53 as a key example.
Surely, there are roles of the immune microenvironment in
keeping those lesions from progressing.
But what I'll talk about today are the non-immune microenvironmental
mechanisms that are at play in the pancreas.
And really, these tumor suppression mechanisms likely vary
from individual to individual, and probably some mathematical modeling is needed
to infer temporal dynamics among the three.
So we really wanted to look in the mesenchyme to see if it could teach us about any
new obligate barriers to tumorigenesis.
And this was a project led by a wonderful graduate student in the lab, Catherine
Onyate, together with her lab mates, Chet and Shahini.
So before I get into the data, I just want to talk about what's in the pancreatic
mesenchyme. There's a kind of cell in both the pancreas and the liver called a
stellate cell. These are lipid-storing cells that can sense and
respond to the presence of cancer or a wound-healing insult and
give rise to activated fibroblasts.
It's not the whole story, though, and we know this just based on how we
isolate these cells in the lab. So if you want to isolate stellate cells from
normal, healthy pancreas or liver tissue, you make a single cell suspension,
you run it through a density gradient, and because these stellate cells are such
robust lipid-storing cells, they'll stay trapped at the
interface of this density gradient.
What you see sinking into this dense layer on the bottom is a bunch
of these conventional PDGF or alpha-positive tissue-resident
fibroblasts, which are also sitting in the tissue, also poised to
sense and respond to the presence of cancer and give rise to CAFs.
Just showing you a little bit of evidence that these cells are different.
Right after you plate these stellate cells in culture, you can see the
cytoplasmic lipid droplets, even evident by bright fields.
Within a couple of days, these cells will sort of spontaneously undergo
activation to sort of a myofibroblast-like
morphology. But within those lipid droplets, they store
esterified vitamin As, retinol esters, and they have this characteristic
blue-green autofluorescence that you can even see in your tissue culture microscope
using the DAPI channel. And so, these are different
populations that are poised to give rise to CAFs.
I'm really not going to talk about differences between these populations in normal
tissues or tumors today. But I did just want to make one point,
given that reading abstracts for this meeting, it's just so clear that this
theme has emerged with respect to the importance of spatial niches
in regulating cell function, molecular profiles, and
tumor outcomes. And I think this idea that there are different mesenchymal lineages
that live in our pancreas and give rise to CAFs is really consistent with that.
So specifically, stellate cells in liver and pancreas are in the
perivascular niche, whereas these conventional fibroblasts generally
accumulate in peri-ductal and peri-acinar spaces. Okay.
So in thinking about how to study these, there's a really nice Cre-based mouse
model, the FEBP4 Cre model, that's been used to study
adipocytes in vivo. So needless to say, this is not a stellate cell-specific Cre.
But what's nice is that it robustly induces recombination in sort of
professional fat-storing cells in the body.
And this includes stellate cells in the pancreas and liver, but does not
include conventional fibroblasts. So it's a way to kind of pick apart the two.
This can be combined with lineage tracing tools, in this case, the
Rosa MTMG allele. So we can indelibly label
stellate cells and the CAFs derived from them in green.
And so in this study, we really wanted to understand the temporal dynamics
of mesenchymal activation during pancreatic tumorigenesis and really
understand what gets lost. And in this case, instead of looking at all the
fibroblasts in the pancreas, all the fibroblasts in the tumor, we thought
maybe we'll learn something new if we look at a more focused
population and track it over time.
So we're going to focus on this lipid-storing origin and the CAFs derived from them
in this example. Okay, so what we did is we took this
reporter model. We took stellate cells from a healthy pancreas
tissue, CAFs derived from them from tumors, and did single-cell RNA-seq on
these GFP-positive cells. So just as sort of a sanity check, we
looked at these cells in both normal tissues on the left and tumors
on the right. We see that they sort of express all the classic mesenchymal markers.
They pervasively express vimentin.
They're along this continuum from PI16 positivity
to collagen 15A1 positivity. This is the trajectory
of universal fibroblasts that was reported in the study from Shannon Turley
and Matt Buechler that Stephanie mentioned earlier.
And most of them express one of the universal fibroblast markers, collagen
4A1 or HSPG2 or perlecan. I did
mention that these are in the perivascular niche.
In the liver, stellate cells have been called the pericytes of the liver, though
I'll just mention they seem to lack robust expression of conventional
pericyte markers.Okay, so then what are the differences across
tissue states? So in the context of tumorigenesis, these
cells gain expression of the expected players, immune suppressive
cytokines, CCL2, IL6, and IL33, just as a few
examples. So we looked at what gets lost, and we really wanted to
look at factors with the potential to function in a paracrine manner and
influence other cell states in the tissue.
And a gene that really leapt out from this analysis was a gene called Kit ligand
or stem cell factor, which was clearly expressed in normal pancreas
tissue but really seemed to be lost in tumors.
And this is consistent with a pseudotime analysis that we performed on these
cells. Okay, so what is Kit ligand?
Generally, Kit ligand is a paracrine factor that is
expressed by so-called sender cells in either a
membrane-associated or a secreted form.
It signals through a receptor c-Kit on the surface
of receiver cells and generally is thought to
activate mitogenic processes and pathways, Ras MAP kinase
signaling, Jak-Stat, and PI3 kinase/AKT signaling.
There is certainly a precedent for thinking about Kit ligand in the
context of the mesenchyme. For example, there was a really nice study some time
ago
showing that there are leptin receptor-positive mesenchymal
cells that indeed express Kit ligand, and these are specifically
hepatic stellate cells in the fetal liver.
And this Kit ligand expression by hepatic stellate cells is actually critical for
normal hematopoiesis in the fetal liver at the appropriate
stage of embryogenesis. Now, this idea that leptin
receptor-positive mesenchyme expresses Kit ligand is something that's been
reported in other anatomic contexts, including the bone marrow stroma.
So we asked, okay, are we looking at actually a leptin receptor-positive
component of the pancreas? And so what we did
is we looked at quiescent stellate cells taken fresh from mouse
pancreas, saw that these actually express really high levels of the leptin
receptor. But when these cells are just spontaneously activated to a fibroblastic
state in culture, they lose the expression of this leptin receptor,
suggesting that indeed, this is part of this kind of anatomically conserved
population of leptin receptor-positive mesenchymal cells that for some
reason express Kit ligand. Okay. So we were motivated to ask
what is the functional significance of this factor in normal pancreas
tissue? But first, we really wanted to validate that it was expressed in mice
but also in human pancreas. So we did a number of
experiments doing RNA in situ hybridization.
Kit ligands, like a number of other secreted factors, just cannot be reliably
detected by conventional immunohistochemistry using commercially available
antibodies.
So we did a series of RNA fish experiments showing indeed that
the mesenchymal component of mouse pancreas expresses
Kit ligand. And importantly, we used floxed alleles, this is a model
I'll get back to later, to show that our RNA fish
experimental approach was specific.
So we then went on to look at human pancreas tissues.
We costained for vimentin to mark mesenchyme and Kit ligand, and we
indeed saw expression of Kit ligand in human pancreas tissue.
And importantly, though there is, of course, an exuberant mesenchymal
population in human pancreatic cancer, we saw a significant
reduction of Kit ligand-positive mesenchyme in invasive
cancer. And this was, of course, conserved in mice.
Okay, so we wanted to really confirm this further in the human pancreas, but also
really assess the relevance of this mesenchymal population we were
studying in mice. And so we leveraged a protocol we're employing where we're
taking pieces of benign pancreas tissue from humans.
These are people who come into Memorial Hospital for resection of a primary
tumor, so I can't call this normal pancreas tissue.
This is benign adjacent. That's a meaningful caveat there.
But we've worked out a pipeline similar to what we do in mice, where we can take
this benign pancreas tissue, subject it to density centrifugation.
We can isolate fibroblasts. We can isolate stellate cells and study those on their
own, or either co-culture them with organoids or
culture them on collagen-coated plates together with cancer cell-derived secreted
factors in the form of conditioned media to make CAFs from them.
And so we see that the stellate cells look like stellate cells, kind of similar to
what we see in mice with these abundant cytoplasmic lipid droplets.
We see this in every patient that we've analyzed so far.
And when you culture them, both the stellate cells and the fibroblasts very readily
give rise to really what looks like a conventional myofibroblast or a
CAF.And so we looked in these cells to see if they express Kit ligand, and the
good news is that they do.
When we take these fresh out of human pancreas tissue, they express this marker.
But when we activate them, either with conditioned media or just with recombinant
TGF-beta, we see a significant reduction of this factor.
So it seemed like this was a thing. So we then wanted to ask, okay,
we've looked in normal, we've looked in cancer.
What happens in between? And so we wanted to look in the context of
pannens. And so we went back into our mouse models, and we used a dual
recombinase genetically engineered mouse model that allows us for
fate mapping of stromal evolution in the context of stepwise
tumorigenesis. So this is something that's missed when we do orthotopic
transplantation of invasive cancer cells.
But these genetically engineered mouse models go through these pre-invasive
stages that many of us harbor. And so when we looked in
pannen lesions from pancreas tissue, we saw that
really this GFP positive mesenchymal seems to be sort of at
a steady state of abundance in pre-invasive lesions versus
tumors. And when we looked at Kit ligand, we saw really
negligible signal in regions of invasive cancer.
But we saw some retention in the GFP positive stroma in the
context of these pre-invasive lesions.
And this is something we really want to look into further.
The last piece before we went forward with functional studies was, is its
partner there? Does it have someone to talk to?
And so we looked at expression of c-Kit in normal pancreas tissue, and
we did see expression of both c-Kit itself, as well as the activated
phosphorylated form, in both human and mouse
pancreas. I will mention that the c-Kit and Kit ligand,
it's rare, and it's in these defined niches where both the receptor
and the ligand are in the same region.
That's something we can maybe talk about during Q&A.
And so together we thought, all right, this is a thing.
This is active in normal pancreas. What does it do?
And so we addressed that by doing transcriptional profiling and loss and
gain-of-function systems, and also perturbing Kit ligand in conditions of
health, injury, and cancer in vivo.
So first, to do transcriptional profiling, we used stellate cells in
culture. They really give rise to CAFs nicely when
you culture them. But the approximation of stellate cells in culture really is
something in between what's normal and what's a CAF.
Because in culture, of course, they're not really exposed to the rich milieu of
factors that's in an intact tumor.
And so we reasoned that probably to really understand what Kit ligand is doing
here, we should do both gain and loss of function experiments to knock
down Kit ligand to where it is in a tumor and to overexpress it to where
it is in normal pancreas. And so we did both and did molecular
profiling by RNA-seq to understand what Kit ligand does.
I'll just briefly mention that subpopulations of these cells express c-Kit, so the
Kit ligand had someone to talk to in these cultures.
And so what we found is that Kit ligand seems to positively regulate
a network of genes that we would predict is associated with
maintenance of normal tissue architecture.
So this includes a number of components of basement membrane and
matrix components, really, that are associated with keeping our tissues intact.
But we also saw negative regulation of factors that are
involved really in detrimental CAF functions, including
LRRC15. This was a marker described by Shannon Turley's lab
that may or may not be functional itself, but marks a CAF state really
associated with immune suppression and resistance to immunotherapy.
It also negatively regulated expression of a number of immune suppressive cytokine
and chemokine genes. And generally speaking, our loss and gain-of-function
experiments agreed with one another.
So from here, we moved into functional studies. We started in just healthy mice.
We conditionally deleted Kit ligand in the pancreatic mesenchymal.
We did H&E, saw no differences. But we were
undeterred, so we crossed in a reporter.
Of course, still no difference by H&E, but really thought to take a look under the
hood, and we did some multiplexed imaging analysis using
CODEX in collaboration with Sung Kim's lab at Stanford.
And so really, there were two differences that caught our eye and motivated us to
keep going. The first is that when we conditionally deleted Kit ligand,
we saw this significant increase in CD45 positive cells or
leukocytes that were recruited into pancreas tissue.
And the second, which we think is related, is an increase in the abundance of
perivascular mesenchymal, or these cells that are touching
endothelial cells. And these cells in those positions really are spatially
poised to secrete factors into the bloodstream that promote leukocyte
trafficking or that impact endothelial cells to regulate leukocyte
trafficking themselves. So from here, we moved into an
inflammatory setting, and we engaged a protocol that's been used
heavily by our colleagues in the field using this secretagogue called
cerulean that induces damage of the acinar compartment
and pancreatic inflammation. And in wild-type healthy mice, you
can treat with cerulean. You get an inflammatory reaction in the pancreas, and
that inflammation resolves within a few days.
This has been really nicely benchmarked by many of our colleagues in the field.
I will mention, though, that a combination of cerulean and a
K-RAS mutation gives something very different.
In that case, the inflammation does not get resolved and actually really
drives the formation of pre-invasive lesions in mouse pancreas.
And so what we found, really to our surprise, is that when we induced
pancreatic inflammation in the absence of Kit ligand, we saw really much more
inflammation, as well as a clear increase in what looked
like an acinar-to-ductal metaplasia within the
pancreatic epithelium. And this really aligned with what people have reported in
the context of a K-RAS mutation in the pancreatic epithelial compartment,
motivating us to ask whether there's some sort of paracrine
inverse relationship between Kit ligand in the stroma and
K-RAS signaling in the epithelium.And so we wanted to look a
little bit more carefully at this idea that kit ligand negatively
regulates epithelial plasticity.
This acinar to ductal metaplasia is an early step of pancreatic
tumorigenesis. And so you can see that in our control mice,
you see that most of these acinar cells express amylase.
The ductal cells express pan cytokeratin.
Generally, these are in different cellular compartments.
But when we conditionally knocked out kit ligand, we really saw fairly
extensive co-expression of these markers consistent with
this metaplastic state that's an early stage of
tumorigenesis. And when we looked at the immune composition of these
tissues, we saw a significant increase in CD45 positive
cells and CD68 positive myeloid cells when we had
this conditional kit ligand deletion.
And finally, we looked in the context of cancer.
And what we've now seen in three different implantable models is that when you lose
kit ligand in the stroma, you significantly increase
tumorigenesis. And we're totally
aware of the limitations of the implantable models, but the one point I want to
make here is that in these cases, these are insta-tumor, right?
They've already lost P53. They are invasive cancer.
But even in this case, kit ligand has some sort of tumor restraining
impact at the tissue level, something we certainly want to look into further.
And so to conclude, I hope I've convinced you that normal pancreatic cancer is
not the barrier, but a barrier to tumorigenesis.
We nominate stromal kit ligand as one factor that seems to limit
epithelial plasticity and inflammation.
The real relevance for epithelial sulfate is something we've only just started to
look into and think about. In human pancreas tissue, we really need to
dig deeper and understand where and when kit ligand gets lost
during tumorigenesis. And of course, we want to really better
understand what's happening in this dual recombinase genetic mouse model to
understand what happens to PanIN progression in these mice.
And the ultimate goal really is to think about downstream mediators that may serve
as targets for interception or as biomarkers of progression.
And so with that, I'll conclude. I'll thank all the wonderful people in my lab,
especially Kathrina, who did this work.
Thanks to our wonderful collaborators and funding sources.
And with that, I'll thank you all for your attention and gladly take any questions.
Very nice talk. And you mentioned there's a key
role of the kit ligand during the
pancreatic cancer progression, right?
So I'm curious about the loss of the kit
ligand expression in CAF. Is it a consequence or trigger of
the poor cancer progression? Thank you.
Yeah, no, it's a great question. So I sort of glossed over it, but
TGF-beta alone was sufficient in our, at least,
experimental culture models to induce loss of kit
ligand from the mesenchyme. So TGF-beta gets induced in the
pancreatic epithelium pretty early in tumorigenesis.
So I think a possibility is that kit ligand sticks around kind
of in the early stages of tumorigenesis, but once there's enough TGF-beta,
then kit ligand gets downregulated, and it's presumably part of a
program that serves as a barrier to tumorigenesis.
I think probably there are other signals in an
intact tumor. We did the is TGF-beta sufficient.
We haven't knocked out TGF-beta in the context of conditioned media, for example,
to ask whether it's necessary with all those other signals around.
But certainly, that's a key factor that we think probably mechanistically is
related to kit ligand regulation and expression.
Got it. Thank you.
Thank you.
So great talk. I'm Yue Fan from Johns Hopkins.
So I noticed that you used like a
PanIN as a model study. So I'm wondering whether like
IPMN to PDAC progression
share the similar
pathway you mentioned, or there's some other different mechanism. Thank you.
Yeah, no, it's a great question. One I don't have an answer to right now.
We were motivated by these totally striking human
studies from Laura's lab and Marina's lab showing how frequent PanINs are.
But these cystic lesions like IPMNs are reasonably common
too, and they all do have their own so-called microenvironment, right?
There is a modest stromal expansion around all of those lesions.
I have no idea what they're comprised of.
I have no idea what the kind of kit ligand expression is, but really, this
was a very mousey work, and we're really motivated to go into humans
and try to understand expression patterns in pre-invasive lesions of
different stages compared to cancer.
And also, we're so fortunate that we have now nice genetic
models that actually
enable us to study IPMNs, to study cystic lesions in the lab.
So it's something we haven't touched yet.
My sort of naive thinking is there's TGF-beta
around in all of them, so perhaps similar rules would apply, but we have to do the
experiment. I think it's a very valid question. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you. Very nice talk. I'm impressed by the stellate
cells. Do you know if there are any other organs where something like that happen?
Because you mentioned two endodermic organs, and
there are other organs that need fatty acids too, so.
Yeah. So, liver is really the original site where stellate
cells were discovered a century ago.
There's a really, really nice Cre-based mouse model, the L-RAT Cre model, that's
been used for studying stellate cells in liver.
Unfortunately, pancreatic stellate cells use something else to
esterify retinoids. They don't express L-RATs. We can't use that in pancreas.
Fabp4 Cre is a tool that we can use in both organs, but we don't have
an L-RAT Cre of the pancreas. But one thing
I'll say that's interesting, bona fide stellate cells have only
been found in pancreas and liver. But what' CAFs cool is there was a sort
of meta-analysis, one of these kind of harmonized
single-cell RNA-seq studies in sort of a pan-cancer study
that came out in cancer research, I think last year, that actually
showed what they called Fabp4-positive pericytes that they
inferred to be major origins of CAFs across tissues.
And so I have to wonder whether this idea of a
fat-storing perivascular cell of origin is
actually a more anatomically conserved feature than we think, if that makes
sense.
Exactly. Back to the thing, pericyte is supposed to be a
reparative cell, and now you're saying that you have a
fat-saving pericyte cell now, which is great.
Exactly.
Thank you.
Yeah. Exactly. Thank you.
Very interesting data. So other than TGF-beta, were you able to
recognize anything else upstream that gets induced?
Because if you think about therapeutic potential, it will be easier to
down-regulate a target rather than overexpress it,
right? And TGF-beta, we already saw the failures.
So were you able to recognize something else, or that's something you're trying
now?
Yeah, it's definitely something we're trying now.
I think ultimately, one thing I didn't talk about, just
briefly covered in the background about Kit ligand is that conventionally,
c-Kit is an oncogenic signaling mediator.
We were certainly surprised by our results, but I
don't think we would want to specifically agonize the
Kit ligand c-Kit pathway as a preventative or therapeutic strategy.
So we're really motivated to look
really mechanistically in both the sender and receiver cells to think about, okay,
probably we don't want to target this specific pathway, but what's associated
functionally? What underlies this apparent link between Kit
ligand and this kind of negative regulation of inflammation and tissue
plasticity? Some of the things that popped out are some of these
basement membrane and matrix components, some
integrins, laminins, other factors that, generally speaking, are
associated with normal tissue architecture.
And if we can understand the molecular regulators of those, I think those would be
really appealing targets. In thinking about the question that came up during
Stephanie's talk of how do we reprogram or
favor a tumor-restraining
fibroblast phenotype, and I think one that promotes a normal, if you
will, matrix and basement membrane architecture, that would be
appealing. We don't know the specific molecular mediators to chase yet, but we're
motivated to look.
Yeah, I think instead of switching between good and the bad, because there's so
little known, bringing them back to the quiescent would probably be the best
bet.
Yeah, for sure.
All right. Thank you.
Okay.
The timer's already started countdown, so I better get going.
Thank you for inviting me. It's
been a great session. It's going to be completely downhill from here.
So
what I'll talk about is some of the work going on in the
lab.
Firstly,
I have no disclosures.
So essentially,
I think as a starting point, just to reiterate the complexity of the tumor
microenvironment in pancreatic cancer, that we have a
multitude of heterocellular interactions
that are present and that really drive tumor progression.
And that we've had, through many years, several studies that have
really
identified these key signaling pathways
that mediate these intercellular interactions.
And similarly, as was just
reiterated earlier, a number of preclinical studies
have really demonstrated quite clearly that, at least in the preclinical models,
if we target some of these interactions, we can
sensitize these tumors to standard care chemotherapy, and in some
cases, we can even make them sensitive to immune
checkpoint inhibitors.
But also, as we were just discussing,
other studies have really illustrated that it's not just
a free target for all to target this tumor microenvironment.
There's a certain level of buyer beware that if you go after
specific subsets, such as with a smoothened
inhibitor and sonic hedgehog targeting,
or specific depletion of certain fibroblast subsets or T
regulatory T cells, you actually see an
acceleration of tumor development or tumor progression.
And actually, where that leaves us is in this
scenario where we have
multiple heterogeneous interactions in
the tumor microenvironment, and that we probably have the
coexistence of both
tumor-suppressive and tumor-promoting interactions
between tumor cells and cells in the microenvironment.
And so,
my
co-chairs or co-speakers here have already
gone through this in much greater
detail than me, but just really to emphasize that we
have multiple subsets of fibroblasts
in these tumors. And a lot of effort have really gone into
classifying these based on the transcriptional
and cell surface marker, and we have an
emerging understanding of their function.
And a lot of them seems to have really
pro-tumorigenic functions, at least the way that it's
been described. And so the question is really, where does the
anti-tumor function sit, and how
can we think about this? But also, more conceptually,
I think as we move forward and start thinking about
targeting fibroblasts in these cancers,
both for pancreatic cancer and also in other cancers, I think there's just
some considerations that are worthwhile just going through.
So we have these subtypes, and we know that they're plastic, there can be switches
between them. But when you start overlaying lineages, it's worthwhile just
really thinking about whether the particular function that's being
interrogated is really restricted to the lineage or whether it's a
compounding effect of the lineage plus the subtype.
And so, this creates some thinking in and around
how do we actually identify these subsets, and what's the
right way to target them?We know that there's a spatial
relationship between tumor cells and fibroblasts, and other cells as
well. So how does this play into how we target the
fibroblasts?
What about tissue specificity? We have a much
better understanding of the fibroblasts and the fibroblast function within the
primary tumor, in particular in pancreatic cancer, compared to what happens
in metastatic sites. And if we are thinking about targeting these fibroblasts,
there's a bit of an underlying assumption that they do the same thing across all
tissues, and I think emerging evidence suggests that that's probably not the
case. Also, in terms of the cellular interactions, are
we going after interactions between fibroblasts immune cells,
fibroblast tumor cells, and is the consequence of targeting those,
is that the same? And finally, I think it's
also worthwhile thinking about whether the
interaction that we're going after is actually
a dominant effect that's really being
driven from the fibroblast, or whether the change in
fibroblast phenotype or transcriptional output is really a
consequence of the environment in which it's sitting.
And so therefore really being very careful in terms of how we select
our targets and how we test them
mechanistically before we go forward.
And so just to illustrate some of these points, I'll just go through
three examples
in a bit more detail. So the first thing is just
sort of related to the relationship between
lineages or more stable fibroblast functions, for lack of a
better term, versus the sort of subset, more
plastic function. So we described in the lab a couple of
years ago, this marker CD105,
that sort of denotes two different subsets or
perhaps even lineages of fibroblasts.
And both of these subsets can adapt the
transcription profile of myofibroblasts, inflammatory fibroblasts,
and antigen-presenting fibroblasts.
And so the way we actually ended up identifying those was using a
slightly orthogonal approach to the single-cell sequencing, where we used mass
cytometry to probe cell surface receptors, and this
was in collaboration with Jen Morton from Scotland Institute.
That really allowed us, based on the KPC model, to identify the
CD105 positive and CD105 negative cancer-associated
fibroblasts. But the sort of experiment that got us really
excited about this was when we take the fibroblasts out from the normal healthy
pancreas and grow them in vitro, the fibroblasts that are
CD105 positive remain CD105 positive, and the ones that are
CD105 negative stay CD105 negative, giving us
sort of an early indication that this is a stable marker expression.
And actually, when we treat these cells with either TGF-beta, interleukin, or
interferon gamma, again, we don't see the sort of shift in
terms of between positive and negative CD105
fibroblasts.
These fibroblasts population subsets or
lineages were also defined by a sort of a differential
response to common signals present in the microenvironment.
So if we take these fibroblasts and treat them with a
number of different signaling
factors that are known to play important roles in the tumor
microenvironment, and then we use mass cytometry to
profile single-cell phospho-specific readout, we can see
that the sort of response to these common signal
differs between the positive and negative fibroblasts, suggesting not
only that they express this differential
receptor, but actually the way that they interpret the same
signal from the microenvironment is actually inherently
different between these two populations.
And what we could also see is that they have a differential function in terms of
how they regulate tumor development.
So if we do a subcutaneous implantation of
tumor cells and then co-implant CD105 positive fibroblasts, we see
a slight acceleration of tumor development or tumor growth.
But if we implant CD105 negative fibroblasts or even
co-implant CD105 negative and CD105 positive fibroblasts,
we can see that there's a suppression of tumor growth, and this
is actually dependent on a functional immune system.
What we don't know yet, and this is something we're actively exploring, is
whether these sort of functional effects is
not only encoded within the CD105 positive and
negative subsets, but actually whether that's dependent on them adapting
a particular myofibroblastic or inflammatory fibroblastic
subset, trying to link the distinction or the interplay between
the sort of hard-coded functions and the more
plastic functions of fibroblasts.
But what we also noticed is that when we start
probing these fibroblast subsets across a
larger number of models here using different genetic
engineered mouse models, we can see that not only are the
CD105 positive and CD105 negative fibroblasts
identifiable across a number of models and also
in human tissues. But what we can see is that when we
look more broadly across a number of the sort of very
well-described markers of fibroblast subsets, that
the abundance of these markers differ
highly depending on the tumor origin, right?
So if we look at something like alpha-SMAOr a
very useful marker of myofibroblasts.
We can see that that's
very well expressed, abundant in fibroblasts from the
pancreas, the colorectal models, and breast cancer.
But in other models, it's just much less abundant, even though the
fibroblast's there. And so it led us to speculate,
when we're thinking about fibroblast subsets, their
presence, and the different
origin of these fibroblasts, how can we start getting a
handle on this in terms of the different subsets and whether there
are tissue-restrictive or tissue-specific functions?
And so the way we've started probing this is using implantation
models, and coupling that with mass cytometry readouts.
So in this particular case, we take
cell lines, we implant them into the pancreas, the liver, and the lung, and then we
probe that. And the benefit of the system is that we can control
the cell line, so it's not an evolution of the cell line.
When we see differences, it's the same cell signal
the fibroblast and the tumor microenvironment is exposed to, but we are
essentially probing the tissue-specific response to
get sort of an experimentally refined way of
interrogating this. And when we do this, and just look at the
sort of mesenchymal marker composition, so this is
just using a panel of about 32 cell surface
markers, and looking in the normal healthy pancreas, the liver, and the
lung. And I don't think we need a lot of statistical analysis to
really say that the fibroblasts based on
these 32 markers between the pancreas, the liver, and the lung, are just
fundamentally different when we probe them in this sort of
high-dimensional space. But what we can also start looking at
is what's the response to tumor growth?
And so we have the pancreas, the liver, and the lung, the healthy and the
tumor-bearing tissue. And when we then take
and cluster these individual fibroblast subsets that have
been identified, and then look at their abundance in
response between the healthy tissue and the
tumor-bearing tissue, and we cluster this in a
hierarchical manner, in an unsupervised hierarchical manner, what we
can see is that the sort of clustering really resembles the
tissue of origin, suggesting that
the response of fibroblasts
to tumor growth is really
restricted based on the tissue of origin, and that there's sort
of a hardwired, encoded way that these
fibroblast subsets respond to tumor growth depending
on the tissue organ. And the control experiment here is to do the
same thing, but looking at immune cells.
And essentially, if we do exactly the same set experiment, we
don't see the same sort of clustering suggesting that there are sort of an
inherent cell-specific way that
these mesenchymal versus immune subsets respond to tissue
damage or tumor growth.
And so to really nail this down a bit more, we then
isolate fibroblasts from the different organs and expose them to
conditioned media from various tumor cell lines.
And when we then start again probing, use a mass cytometry against
these cell surface receptors, we can see again that the way
that the fibroblast responds is really encoded
depending on the tissue of origin, suggesting that the tissue of
origin might dictate the fibroblast response to tumor growth.
And so I think it causes a bit of pause in terms of thinking about,
well, if we target one of these interactions in one organ, we
really need to be sure that we see the same or at least a
non-antagonistic effect of that in a different organ.
And so the benefit of this could be that maybe actually we can use this as a
way to think about doing tissue-specific targeting of
fibroblasts, but we need to think about the sort of broader consequences
of that.
So, the sort of last example I'll highlight here is sort of
like, so how do we think about probing this
in a system whereby we can really
control,
in a very detailed mechanistic manner, the interactions
between the cellular subsets to understand what
happens within the cells, but also ultimately how
the tumor cells respond to this. And so this is some work
that's been ongoing in my lab, and this is really based on
collaboration, in particular with Linda Griffith, who's a
fantastic bioengineer out of MIT.
And the sort of system that she's helped us develop,
is a fully synthetic PEG gel system that allows us to
do co-cultures between
patient-derived
organoids together with primary
pancreatic fibroblasts or fibroblasts from other organs.
And we can then include in vitro differentiated immune cells as well.
And so when we start doing this, we can sort of start putting the model
system together where we have the direct co-culture between defined
cellular subsets. And this is just really to show that
we have cellular interactions between the tumor
cells, the immune cells, and the sort of fibroblasts you can
see with the phalloidin stain here. And we got decent viability.
But the sort of like,
I think really exciting outcome here is that when we
take fibroblasts, and when we take this model
system and we start probing it by using single-cell
RNA sequencing,
even though we, in this particular experiment, take
fibroblasts from the normal healthy pancreas
and then co-culture them with the tumor cells
and also the immune cells, we can see that the fibroblasts
from the same sample start adapting these
sort... subset transcriptional profiles.
So we've got
cells starting to look like myofibroblasts,
MHC class II positive, CD74 positive, APCAFs.
We've got ICAFs and complement secreting CAFs as well, suggesting
that we can start rebuilding the
tumor microenvironment using these bottom-up
approaches.
And what we can also see is that we have a
tumor cell response that differs.
So when we're looking in the tumor cells here,
cultured by themselves together with fibroblasts and together with immune cells and
fibroblasts, we can see that we have loss of transcriptional
subsets and gain of other transcriptional subsets, and they actually
correspond to more EMT, a more basal type
transcriptional subsets, suggesting that when we rebuild these sort of
interactions,
we can start recapitulating some of the more aggressive
features that we see in patients. But also that
different patient-derived organoids respond
differently to these interactions, suggesting that we can also
start recapitulating some of the heterogeneity that we
know or struggle to recapitulate in these preclinical
models. So we've now started using this to
probe a bit more detail what actually happens in the tumor cells
as they are co-cultured. And as sort of a starting point, we focused
on looking at RAS,
just because it seems to be important in pancreatic cancer.
But here, what we've been doing is we've taken a
TurboID TAC to RAS, and then we can
start probing is the number of proteins that are
proximal to RAS as a consequence of
the organoids being cultured by themselves in the presence of
fibroblasts and the presence of fibroblasts and immune cells.
And what you can sort of start seeing emerging here is that we have
a vast expansion of the proximal
protein network around
KRAS as we increase the cellular heterogeneity in these
models, suggesting that the way that the tumor cells
respond to a high degree of cellularity
really impacts the subsequent signaling
dynamics within the tumor cells.
And so what I've hoped to touch upon a little
bit is that fibroblasts, they can
regulate the tumor microenvironment as a
whole in multiple ways. I think we're
still trying to really work out as a community which of
these effects are really dominant to tumor cell
function, to tumor development, and identifying those,
I think, is a very important first step to really thinking about how we can
target these interactions.
Some of the other things that I think would be very important to understand,
and certainly there are ongoing efforts, is to really understand how
the evolution of the interactions between the fibroblast
microenvironment and the tumor cells
is during treatment, and also how the
sort of spatial interactions impact CAF
biology and how that might apply to
therapeutic response. So with that, I want to thank the
people in the lab who've been instrumental to doing this work,
the funders, and I'm happy to take any questions. Thank you.
We actually do have one online question, but it's for Mara,
sorry.
Asking about your modulation of Kit ligand
and the induction of CD45 positive cells.
Do you have a rationale for why that happened?
Our guess for now is that when we inhibit Kit ligand in this
population, we increase expression of a number of inflammatory
cytokines and chemokines in the lineage.
So I think even in normal tissue, when these fibroblasts aren't
in an activated state, it's still an
increase in various chemoattractant cues that are
presumably bringing the immune cells in.
But another possibility is they're sitting right next to endothelial cells.
So it's totally possible that they're also changing adhesion molecules on
endothelial cells that are impacting leukocyte trafficking.
So those would be probably my two guesses.
Great. And then one for Claus. Do we have any insight
into the tumor cell cues that impact CAF expression of
CD105?
Well, so CD105 is
a co-receptor of the TGF
beta
receptor.
So we know that if we treat fibroblasts
with TGF beta, we see an increase in
the level of CD105. But the sort of
fundamental expression where we-- So we haven't identified any
signals so far that turns on CD105
in a CD105 negative fibroblasts. So the ones that are
negative seems to stay negative.
Okay.
Hi, Claus. Bobby Norgard, Boehringer Ingelheim. Nice talk.
Thank you.
Kind of odd question.
As I think about where you're pulling fibroblasts from different tissues and
showing how they're very different depending on where they come from.
Yeah.
The idea of making a fibroblast normal is not an
unoriginal idea. But to my knowledge,
fibroblasts are usually not a good thing in cancers.
To your knowledge, is there a cancer type where fibroblasts are a good
thing?And should we be thinking about not turning CAFs normal, but turning
CAFs to a different tissue of residence?
So I need that again. Sorry.
Yeah.
It might be the jet lag.
It was kind of an odd question.
It's kind of thinking about changing CAFs, reprogramming CAFs, not
to a normal state-
Mm-hmm
... but to a different residence state.
Yeah.
And I don't have a great example for this, but in
fibroblasts in breast cancer, they're usually bad, and fibroblasts in pancreas
cancer, they're usually bad. But if you took breast cancer fibroblasts and put them
in pancreas
tumors-
Yeah
... would that now be a better situation?
It's just a different way of thinking about reprogramming instead of pushing them
back to normal, which I don't know what normal actually means.
Yeah.
Well, the short answer is I don't know.
So
I think it's an intriguing question.
So in fairness, I think
a lot of emphasis over the years have been to try and target fibroblasts
because they are there, and they are abundant.
And so I think that
has led a lot of efforts to try and show that they are
pro-tumorgenic. I think the sort of efforts to try and
understand how might they
do the other thing, how might they be anti-tumor development, I think
that's lacking behind. So, I think we still have a
lot to learn, in particular, as Mara alluded to,
the sort of early stages of tumor development, what's
actually happening there.
So how does a fibroblast function differ between
organs?
That's a good question. I
don't have the answer to that, but yeah, a good one. Thank you.
Hey, Jen.
Hey, Claus.
Question for you and everybody,
really.
Given Laura and Marina's really nice work on the abundance of
PANNs-
Mm-hmm
... how likely is it, do you think, that
some of the stuff that we can't translate from mouse to human
is because we're having differential effect, the stromal targeting therapies
are having differential effects on the primary versus the
residual PANNs that are kicking about in those models and in the people?
So I think that's very likely. Right.
And I think it
might even extend beyond that, because a lot of
our
current way of probing fibroblast biology is really focused on primary
tumor. So yeah, we can target those.
If they have a different function in pre-cancer lesion, that's
obviously an issue. But also
when we go in clinically, it's typically in metastatic disease.
And so actually, that's compounding the effect there if the function is
different between different organs.
And so I think the emerging evidence suggests that that is the case.
And so I think it's just critically important, as Stephanie alluded
to, is really to learn from the
clinical trials that have already happened, to really try
and probe some of these
questions before we rush into the next trial.
Because it's not good for the patients, and it's not good for the community to
shut down therapies
and the development of therapies just because we're not doing the right
translational workup.
She claims you already answered.
Okay. You're welcome.
What about
fibroblasts going
together in clusters to the metastatic
site?
Mm-hmm.
Is that going to now mingle and mix
the-
Yeah
... heterogeneity and the functions again, or is this really
truly imprinted?
Can we change them? Is it really truly imprinted in what's going to happen with the
travelers?
Yeah. So, and again, that's a good question.
So,
I think a lot of it is hardwired. So if we take the
fibroblasts out and culture them in vitro, we see that the response to
these cues are really hardwired into the fibroblasts.
Sure.
Right? And so that would indicate that even if they travel with the tumor
cells to a site of metastasis, that the way they would respond
at that metastatic site might be similar to what they would respond to in
the primary tumor. I think where
we still don't know enough is
how many of the fibroblasts we're finding,
either in a primary tumor or metastatic site, are from
the tissue of origin versus the ones that have actually either
traveled with the tumor cells or being recruited from the bone marrow, such as
fibrocytes, et cetera.
Right.
And one of the challenges is really
having robust markers that do not
change over time depending on the tissue that they're in.
So how can we track this with epigenetic markers, for
example?
Right. So once we track them, then we need to
study their reciprocity because now they're going to be companions.
Yeah.
Absolutely. I think really picking apart the sort
of
underlying mechanisms of those interactions, I think is going to be critical.
And I think
we haven't really discussed this in much detail here, but in particular, the
structure in and around the ECM as well, I think is just going to be
so important in terms of how those interactions
drive the tumor phenotype and immune phenotype
ultimately.
Yeah, I made you said that.
All right. Oh, you have your question?
Yeah. So maybe this is for the whole panel.
So, given that all of these CAF targeting
approaches work great in mice and then they fail in the
clinic or make it even worse, should we
start thinking about other animal models
in looking at these therapies? Or should we be
comparing the human
setting with the mouse setting a little bit more to figure out what are the exact
differences that account for these phenotypical differences we see with the
different species?
Yeah. So I think that's a very important-- If I may start.
Yeah.
So I think that's a very important question.
So
I would be very careful with discarding the mouse model, right?
Actually, I think some of the fundamental challenges we've had in
terms of translating from mouse into human, I think
some of it is just because we don't understand the
underlying biology well enough. And I think that
some trials have probably been started too early, right?
Where we really haven't understood what we're looking for in the
biomarker.
I think it's worthwhile really thinking about having other models.
I think the best model to study this sort of thing
is ultimately the human patient, right?
And so actually having access to tissue
from clinical trials, even if it's not a stromal
targeting agent, but for any other agent, right?
Would really help us understand the
interaction network and how they respond
under those conditions. I think that the sort of fundamental
biology is really where we're lacking, if you
ask me.
Yeah.
I'll maybe bluntly say what Claus is too humble to say, that I think his approach
really is such a critical way forward to, yes, use mouse models that
incorporate lymphatic vasculature and inter-organ crosstalk
and things that we really need in vivo models for.
But to really have as a critical intermediate step, these sort of the brilliant
engineering platform that you've developed or other kind of patient-derived models
to complement those and at least understand whether some of the
paracrine signaling mechanisms we've seen in mice hold true in
patient-derived models, whatever we choose to make them before moving
forward and translating. It does seem like a critical intermediate that hopefully
will be incorporated more kind of across the field.
Great. Okay, with that, we will close our session. So thank you.
Thank you.
Awesome talks, guys.
Yeah.